gilles eric séralini est de retour dans
l'arène
et cette fois le professeur caennais
s'attaque directement aux méthodes
utilisées pour autoriser les ogm les
pesticides et autres produits chimiques
des substances d'abord testé sur des
rats en laboratoire et comparer un
échantillon témoin dont l'équipe
universitaire a analysé la nourriture
surprise ses croquettes contiennent tel
même une grande variété de ces mêmes
produits et on a même vérifié dans cinq
continents que la nourriture que les
industriels utilisent ait été contaminé
avec de très hauts niveaux de polluants
pesticides ogm dioxines et métaux lourds
et que ça expliquait des taux de
maladies chez les rats normaux qu'il
trouvait comme naturelle alors qu'en
fait elle est sans doute dû à l'ensemble
des contaminants de l'alimentation avec
cette découverte
gilles eric séralini et ses soutiens du
criigen estime que tous les tests
réalisés jusqu'à présent sont
malhonnêtes et mensonger il réclame aux
industriels une plus grande transparence
et un changement de méthode c'est comme
d'imaginer de prendre comme témoin pour
le dopage comme population témoin
monsieur tron voilà c'est la même chose
c'est à dire que les animaux témoins
sont déjà des animaux contaminés et par
voie de conséquence tout est faux quand
on fait les cantons fait les résultats
et surtout quand on prend les études
historiques qui accumule précisément ces
résultats là en 2012 la précédente étude
du professeur caennais sur la toxicité
du roundup et d'un maïs transgénique
avait provoqué une vaste polémique
l'équipe craint à nouveau que les
industriels ne fasse pression sur la
communauté scientifique
l'étude qui devait être publié hier soir
a été retardé au tout dernier moment
hier par téléphone